hey i'm crystal and i'm the producer
behind one of our favorite recipes here
at goodfall which is healthy delicious
and most importantly sustainable so grab
a colander and let's get started
so the first thing we're going to do is
separate the live clams from the dead
clams we're gonna toss out the dead ones
and put the live ones into our colander
so the way to tell if a clam is dead is
to take a look at it and if you give it
a little tap or you squeeze it closed
and it doesn't shut on its own it's
probably dead so you can go ahead and
discard it
if however you pick up a clam and you
tap on it and it shuts on its own then
you know it's alive just be careful to
not let it pinch your fingers so a
really important step when cooking with
clams is to make sure that we clean them
really well beforehand we're going to
want to scrub off all of the impurities
on the outside of the shell like
barnacles and then we're also going to
clean the inside and the way we do that
is by salting a bowl of water really
really well so it sort of emulates sea
water and then we just let the clams sit
in there for a few hours up to overnight
the salty water allows the clams to
purge themselves of grit and sand and
filter the water pushing out any of the
impurities after we let them sit in the
salted water we're gonna move them to a
bowl of clean water and that'll allow
them to sort of spit out all that salt
and get them ready for cooking there are
a lot of benefits to choosing clams over
other types of seafood not only are they
a really great source of protein but
they're also high in omega-3 fatty acids
iron vitamin b6 and b12 and on top of
that they're just a responsible choice
because they're more sustainable what we
mean is that hand-farmed clams are more
sustainable because they cause less
disruption to the environment you see
normally with farmed fish they require
food to maintain themselves and that
food is generally other smaller fish
that are harvested from the ocean which
obviously has negative impacts because
by feeding the fish from the ocean to
the farmed fish we're depleting the food
supply for the wild fish but the cool
thing about clams is that they don't
require feeding since they filter their
nutrients from the water that they're in
there is nothing better to serve this
dish with than a really nice baguette
and it's super easy to make it look
really impressive all you need to do is
slice it up put some olive oil and a
little bit of sea salt on either side
and then use a grill pan to get those
nice crispy marks in it and it's perfect
to dip in the juice and
it's the best
[Music]
i like to add red pepper flakes to this
dish because i love the little bite that
it gives it but if you don't like spice
feel free to leave this step out
next we want to add a little bit of dry
white wine to our aromatics a cheap
sauvignon blanc always works for me
and we just want to give it enough time
to let the alcohol sort of cook out but
leave behind all that great flavor
we're going to finish up our broth by
adding a little bit of brown sugar fish
sauce and vegetable broth if you don't
have fish sauce at home don't worry you
can totally replace this with soy sauce
make sure to go with the canned coconut
milk here and not the one that comes in
a carton there's a really big difference
and the one that comes in a can is gonna
give us that little bit of creaminess
that we're looking for
it's the final step all we have to do is
add our clams to our broth and when you
do this be ready because they're gonna
cook so fast
[Music]
finally i like to garnish the clams with
some scallions and cilantro because i
think it gives it just a really bright
fresh flavor
so the next time that you're craving
seafood you should definitely try this
recipe or another one that has maybe
mussels or oysters because at the end of
the day they're just a more responsible
and sustainable option
did you hear my stomach growl
because i'm thinking about the clowns
i have one more thing to add
what do clams do on their birthday
and they celebrate
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you